I think if anybody can do it it's
Kirstie Alley is that she speaks from
the heart she has lived it she's walked
it she's breathed it and I would trust
Kristi anywhere Valerie is what I would
call a real woman so it means a lot to
me coming from her that she would
validate me in this way both have
endorsed Jenny Craig in the past and now
hi et as you can see Wow 64 year old
Kirstie is back at Cheers with norm
George Wendt and cliff John Ratzenberger
50 pounds down thanks to Jenny Craig no
last time I saw beauty like you I was
there Amy that was Jimmy you're reunited
with Jenny Craig but you also for this
campaign reunited with some old it was
the but you know when they approached me
what do you think about doing a
commercial and cheers and I thought well
who's gonna do that George and John I
was like are they really it's not the
original cheer set that's in a museum so
they built a new one we walked on that
set it could not have been a more
perfect replica I'm we about fainted a
lot of flaws and some rumors out there
about a reunion in fact there's some
specifics like there's a Cheers reunion
coming out in 2017
I want to choose reunion as long as it's
not taken up as a subject it really has
to just be another show it can't be a
very special moment or Fantasy Island or
something you know what I mean we're
both Dancing with the Stars alums and
Kirstie still has got those moves she
tells me read Johnny Jenny Craig was the
key to losing and keeping those fifty
off for good and it really works for me
because I'm not good on my own honestly
guys have to be knocking up at your door
I mean are you David you know I said in
2015 I was gonna say
I did some dating not impressed